okay getting on getting on I'm not young
I'm not a spring chicken anymore I think
it's been hard
um for the last two years because you
I love the sports
I go out there and put in 100 plus miles
and keep going and over the years you
took that for granted and I was going on
a bit my body can't do that anymore and
that's one of the toughest things but
you know I've had the amazing career if
you look back what I have achieved I'm
proud of you know to win so many medals
and
that memorable moment on that Super
Saturday to do that that's motivates me
every day to continue but my body can't
do it anymore and this will be the last
marathon it's just you know it's
something you have to end some point